what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain simply the
best podcasting crypto let's kick this
thing off
Mike Novogratz is the founder and CEO of
galaxy digital in this conversation we
talk about his time at Goldman Sachs and
fortress how he lost billionaire status
and what that meant criminal justice
system and bail reform his thoughts on
privacy and surveillance and what he
believes the future of crypto looks like
I really enjoyed this conversation and
Mike is one of the most thoughtful
people in the space I hope you enjoy
this conversation as well I'm sure a lot
of you have used kayak to find the best
flight total is kind of like kayak but
it don't find you no flights it helps
you find liquidity on decentralized
exchanges then it optimally routes your
trades for execution
so kayak you find flights total they
help you find liquidity we should get
kayak on it for this spot that I'm
providing them but total instead is our
advertiser and you should go visit total
comm / pump again that's total comm /
pump and let them know that I sent you
tell them you love their product take a
screenshot tweet it at me I'll drop you
some fire emojis and it will all be
happy so total comm / pump boom another
add as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long term
safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block by interest account users
can now securely store their Bitcoin or
Ethernet block five and receive 6%
annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly high
rate it's the best rate in the industry
I highly suggest you go check out block
Viacom / pop again that's block 5 com /
pop to sign up and start earning crypto
today Zen Ledger's for all you
accountants and crypto investors out
there trying to get through this bear
market there are fast and simple tax
reporting tool that saves you a ton of
time and headache
and nobody liked dealing with their
taxes so let's n let you do it for you
you can learn more by visiting Zen
ledger io / off-the-chain to get your
taxes done with ease it has an off the
chain listener
you'll get 20% off your 2018 tax forms
that's right
listening to this podcast makes you
smarter and saves you money one more
time the Zen ledger dot IO / off the
chain goes to check it out
Anthony pomp Leone o is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by pump or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only alright guys
I'm here with Mike Novick rotz you are a
legend at this point I think in both
Wall Street and crypto I really
appreciate you coming in and doing this
awesome I'm excited yeah yeah everyone
knows I think a lot of the wall shoot
background but maybe like let's go pre
Wall Street you grew up in Virginia and
then wrestled at Princeton I did I get
ROTC so you did that in college in it in
college you know back then it was a way
to pay for college and I grew up in a
military family and so you didn't even
think you were joining the army just
like your way to pay for college
yep man I wanted to go to Princeton
because Brooke Shields went there and
that seems like a cool place to go
Plus Tom Cruise like went there in risky
business and so it's kind of in the
school of the moment yep
and not many you know kids from my area
were going there and so I afforded it by
doing ROTC and then woke up one day I
was like damn I'm in the army
yeah I became a helicopter pilot in Fort
Rucker Alabama it was a great year one
of favorite years of my life quite
frankly learned the south made a lot of
friends didn't really want to spend
eight years in the army and there was a
track to join the National Guard Reagan
had put too many people in the in the
army at that point in his surge to build
up our defenses he overdid it and so
they're like anyone want to volunteer to
be in the garden
ham was up mm-hmm in a lot of ways
because I really didn't think we were
ever gonna be used in war again I mean
one of the great misjudgments of my life
you know there was glass no sin
perestroika and and even in the army
they were always talking about tank
warfare and you know when we're fighting
the bear
you know the folded gap this is they
were the whole army was set to fight
this ground war in Germany with the
Russians invading and I was like did you
guys don't read the paper and so I was
so smug and I was like I'm joining the
guard I don't want to practice it never
be used and literally my best friend
from flight school I think he was in
combat for about 25 straight years Wow
yeah you know you think about it we
invaded first we went down to Panama you
got Noriega and then you had Desert
Storm one you had you had Bosnia and you
had the second gulf war Afghanistan
I mean look of your kid in America today
and your what 17 18 years old you've
lived your entire life with the US at
war and Middle East yeah and so my
generation of officers and enlisted men
have really spent the bulk of their
career if they stayed in the army in and
around combat and I was convinced we
would never go a little bit wrestling
I put blood buck now and I'm assuming
it's somewhat of a similar experience
but the idea of participating in a
combat sport where there's a team aspect
to it but really when you get on the mat
it's you verse the opponent right what
is that like or what kind of lessons you
learn there that you think help on the
investing side some of the other things
you've done in your career you know
listen wrestling is a sport probably bar
none that teaches toughness toughness
and discipline and so you get the crap
beat out of you and so it teaches
toughest discipline and resilience you
got to get back up and go back to you
know you're not gonna win every match
and so I kind of think it's the grit and
toughness is what you're taken to into
the investing world also discipline you
can't just be a good wrestler you're
you're a good wrestler because you
practice you can't be a good athlete in
anything I mean you know Michael Jordan
shot more basketballs than just about
anybody
Tiger Woods swung more golf clubs and so
the great athletes you know it's
push-ups it's running it's drilling and
and it's
that practice that builds a discipline
that shows up when you're in competition
yeah is that it's the actual work that
you put into it 100% what am i I see
tweeting all the time on Twitter about
the UFC and some of these guys who are
going I've been actually pretty shocked
that there hasn't been pressure
conversation about that becoming a
collegiate sport right just given how
cuz that if it is in popular value yes
it's interesting so I have been a big
advocate for both high school and
college wrestling and Olympic wrestling
it's been a big part of my philanthropy
and and a lot of my energy and when you
SC first showed up I was really kind of
anti UFC because really I think there's
there's something noble about wrestle
even the rules like I can pick you up
but I got a unresponsible protein back
to the mat and USC felt just to thuggy
it felt like too barbaric almost like
you know frickin dogfighting huh and
remember the original UFC there were
less rules than there are they say they
put gloves on them right you couldn't
kick people when they're down any and we
we really had to be careful when we were
getting wrestling into New York City
schools who are now in I think you know
almost 200 different schools there we
might group beat the streets as slowly
when we started there were 25 schools
that had wrestling we don't really
differentiate ourselves from UFC and say
no it's not this violence more listen
UFC has become more mainstream lots of
my friends are participants I mean
actually three of the champs right now
are guys that are my wrestling guys yeah
really
Cormier is a great friend of mine that
aspirins a buddy Henry cejudo is like my
little brother and so for me it's been
fun to watch them and but it took me a
long time to kind of come around a UFC
yeah yeah
what do you think about a Conor McGregor
he seems that everyone's attention
O'Connor I saw i sat front row at that
could be fight that was fun and I've had
when he jumped over he thought he was
jumping right at us and he is probably
the most charismatic athlete since
Muhammad Ali in terms of pure charisma
now he's not a quarter of the man a
tenth of the man only was until he was a
oh wait Danna and a real social warrior
and McGregor's just seems to be a fun
guy that's you know a little bit full of
himself but me man does he have charisma
yeah I don't think Ginga listen he's not
gonna have a great Yoshi career from
here mm-hmm the wrestlers are gonna
continue to dominate UFC they just are
you know in a fight when you get you
look what Ben Askren in that last fight
of me he was literally getting destroyed
and stayed in it next thing he choked
the guy out you know what just seems to
like when a wrestler he's an elite
wrestling they get their hands on
somebody get them on the mat it's over
over right yeah yeah all right so you're
in the National Guard helicopter pilot
and all of a sudden you join Goldman and
you go to Asia describe kind of like why
go to Goldman and then why take the job
in Asia versus do something else after I
left the guard I thought I'd go to DC
and join politics and oh really I did I
I love politics I love policy and I
interviewed with lots of jobs and just
nothing paint anything and I had spent
so much money at college I my friends
money I'd I had student loans I was like
to love a good luck big life and you
know those jobs just didn't pay a thing
and so a lot of the guys I got the
entry-level jobs either had wealthy
parents which I didn't or or really were
more committed than I was
if I came to New York and lots of my
friends you know they had started two
years earlier we're working on Wall
Street and you know Princeton Wall
Street is a pretty big connection I ran
into a buddy of mine who got me a job
got me an interview at Goldman and you
know 24 interviews later they gave me a
job and felt like as good a place as any
to work yeah and so I had a 11 year
career there first in sales then in
risk-taking loved it the Goldman is a
cult it's gonna ask about the the
interview process and how that leads
into the culture you know listen it's a
it's it's like playing for the New York
Yankees of your baseball player and so
once you're in the process you think I
want to be on the New York Yankees
it's a wonderful firm they've got a
really strong culture what makes it
wonderful as they hire the best and the
brightest and so they continue to get
great human capital they had this
partnership gig they still do
which keeps you there because you start
defining yourself on God if I'm gonna be
a partner enough and so you get paid
less than you would if you worked to
somewhere else because you had that
chance of the golden ring yep I was
lucky enough to be in the kind of right
seat at the right time and do well
enough that evening became a partner and
it was it was a to this day it's a very
cool fraternity and they have a Goldman
Sachs retired partners dinner every year
and it's shocking how everyone from
around the world that was a partner
comes back just for that dinner really
there's a real tie to that sense of
excellence and sense of you know
greatness that Goldman had has been for
a long period of time it's funny to hear
this because I think that the military
has some were you know kind of tie in
you you know what people went through to
be there thrive there etc I think that
some of these tech companies today right
that really blew up and there were small
teams that eventually built
multi-billion dollar companies and
Goldman I think still today focuses on
the best the brightest and now what
they're even doing is they're going
after new types of people like they've
got this program or they go get military
veterans right I think they get a lot of
n-c-double-a athletes and I so I think
great companies and and great
institutions create extended family you
know Princeton is a really neat place
it's actually people are more excited
about Princeton after they graduate than
when they're there it's hard when
they're there yeah and so you create the
sense of family Goldman has done the
same thing like so again they're being a
retired golden partner there's a synergy
of I do well it makes Goldman look good
if they do well it makes me look good
and so you know they reach out to their
xx partners and keep us engaged as does
Princeton as as do great companies or
great nonprofits and so it's this idea
of you can create identity like we're
all searching for some identity
especially you know some yes you
religion breaking down more and more
people want to feel community and your
job is a place where there's community
it's where your identities for sure what
um what was it like working at a Wall
Street firm in Asia in the 90s so let's
just say you know Asia 94 to 2000 always
thought they were like dog years you
know
you worked 1997 felt like seven years
you had this unbelievable exuberance of
free markets and and in China exploding
north in terms of you know capitalism
just spreading through China it was a
little bit like the Wild West at times I
felt as a market participant an unfair
advantage in that you know JP Morgan and
Goldman Sachs and Barclays and bearings
these are institutions that taught you
how to take risk and think about risk
and understand finance and often we were
competing against let's say in the Thai
crises against a group of risk takers
and traders that didn't have the
education that we did you know and so it
almost felt unfair yep and you know we
did very well and so you think it's
still like that where you think it's the
the talent has really evened out and I
think the talent is evening out realist
in China does not let in US financial
institutions because they still don't
want to compete mm-hmm and they were I
remember sitting with Zhu Rongji who was
really the architect in a lot of ways of
China's great miracle or at least the
second half of it he was like listen
will let in Kodak because we'll be able
to figure out what they do real fast and
then we'll be able to beat them yeah
we're not letting in goldman sachs
we're not letting in JP Morgan not for a
long time and they still have it yeah
they were supposed to have yep and it's
one of these reasons we have this trade
tension now but part of because the jobs
of risk and finance are a little more
subtle than they are say manufacturing
they're getting there listen I I I don't
like competing against the Chinese you
look at our industry I mean I think the
most influential guy in the whole
industry right now is cz and what
they're doing at finance he he's running
a hundred thousand miles an hour now he
doesn't have the same regulatory
oversight that the rest of us are he's
kind of playing the game of catch me if
he can but he's a you know unbelievably
dynamic entrepreneur when we interviewed
him on here I'd spent some time with him
before and was really able to help
unpack why
how he's built it and the part that's
crazy to me is it's one thing to go from
no revenue to a lot of revenue if you're
a high-growth company in a big space and
kind of you ride the trend and you're
benefit from it
he's also built a team of 400 people in
18 months right like and they're
completely there like 40 different
countries that communicate all through
technology and just it's incredible to
scale and stay somewhat efficient and
move at that speed with also hiring 400
people in 40 different countries right
so the when you look back on the last
three four years the most profitable
parts of this industry from a business
perspective this was profitable you
bought a bunch of you know big coin or
theorem in water and you sold it okay
that was great but in terms of building
a business was can you connect into the
gambling culture mm-hmm right the single
best business out there right now is
Arthur Hays like I mean it's just a
freakin money printing machine
but both finance bit mixed they you know
pin Finex they all connected into this
love of Asian gambling mmm you know you
can call it investing it's speculating
is this surge trading speculating
whatever it's in that the being able to
profit on that and you know with that
enthusiasm of what we had us kind of a
speculative bubble literally gave these
guys war chests to now grow out other
businesses and and so be interesting to
see I don't think in the long run those
margins will be sustainable right
there's it's barriers to entry aren't
high enough and so I think the exchange
business will come down some but those
are the guys that have the capital to
invest in new things and hire 400 people
and you know if you took the
institutional route it's been a much
slower route for sure well and I think
the big question is what's more
sustainable over 10 15 years right you
know I think we'll see a big transition
in this industry in the next you know
six months to six years both businesses
are quite valid I think right now
there's almost been very little
institutional business
and so there's a lot of business a lot
of work being on building the
architecture to allow institutions in
the architecture is not just custody and
trading and regulatory architecture it's
also educational architecture it's
education educating the pension funds
and the asset managers on how the system
works and why it's important that latter
oh that our that that's happening and
it's happening not as fast as I'd like
if I've made you know off predictions in
the last you know 12 months it's always
been thinking something would started
then it's four months later than it's
going to be but I'm wildly confident
that it's happening because I see it
every day well in part of it too I think
that's really interesting so before
before we get into the institutional
side one thing I want to cover is you
left Goldman I went to fortress right
and when you went to fortress you were
there when they took the company public
right there was kind of a big financial
windfall event for a lot of people
involved we just walked through like
what was it like going from Goldman to
something that was newer younger and
kind of earlier in its lifecycle and
then what the parallels are that you see
to today with crypto well sure so I
remember sitting around a table you know
fortress existed it was a small company
Wes Eden's founded it and me him and
Pete Berger sat around a table and both
Wes and I had the exact same idea that
one plus one plus one could equate that
was just simple that we could create a
alternative asset manager and have
businesses that had very little to do
with each other other than they were
alternative asset managers and put them
together and create synergy and we set
out we literally drew the business plan
on a napkin we our first contract was
under napkin we kind of used the Goldman
theory of true partnership and so each
of the our businesses we threw a hundred
percent of the the profits into the pot
and then split it up which in some ways
was insane because we had so little to
do with each other like West random a
private equity business and at that
point he was just killing it P Berger
was building a lending you know
specially lending business and he was
just starting out I ran a macro business
but we did it that way
we had great success
four or five years and took the company
public you know in some ways right at
the right time and right at the wrong
time when we were rock stars for a month
it was the the the longest time be
between a stock and stock opening on the
New York Stock Exchange in 15 years and
you know we were 50 times oversubscribed
in her IPO and Wow
and so that was exciting unfortunately
we were in right into the the jaws of
the 2008 financial crises and quite
frankly having built a business as fast
as we did and the heaviness of going
from you know a wealthy guy to a
billionaire to like you know and having
everybody call you and all that goes
with it we we stumbled in oh eight or
you know the P the the the various
businesses I used to kid around about
like the three pigs one was built of
bricks one was built a sticks and one
was built a straw and you know some did
better than others sure but it was it
was humbling there were lessons learned
and I think the big lesson that is
relevant to crypto is it's hard to build
a business that fast and because you
have the two different forces a it's
hard if you're the most sober you know a
person on the planet but when you're
going from Arthur Hays having been a you
know fired from Citibank
to now the richest kid walking around in
Hong Kong it's hard for it not to impact
your judgment your ego your and it
usually takes some lumps and some
stumbling for you to kind of regain your
your balance and so people are gonna
make mistakes they're gonna make
mistakes because they think they're on
you know untouchable when when things
happen it's not so much even just
humbling and when you're building a
business in general right forget the
personal aspects of it the business
gonna go through good times and bad
times and weathering that it's really
hard to build a business like make no
bones about it if I've learned one thing
in Galaxie having this is you know my
first shot going through this stuff is
it's hard to hire the right people it's
hard to get customers signed on it's
like everything is a little harder than
you hope
mm-hmm absolutely all right so you go
through the fortress time and then I
think everyone pretty much knows when
you first started looking at crypto got
excited about it etc what was it like
though to go from being a billionaire to
not a billionaire to back to being a
billionaire like there's only a couple
people in the world who have done that
three times at least three right you
know a lot of it's just psychological
like sigh once I once we got very rich I
never was not really rich so you it's
unfair you know if you're worth six
hundred million dollars or eight
underman dollars or a billion dollars in
lots ways it's just it's the same thing
it's the same thing you're gonna give
less to philanthropy in lots of ways
yeah you can't buy a sports team but
there's nothing in your life or your or
your ability to do new things that
changes it was a lot of fun and it was
empowering to have caught you know the
big coin etherium rally and have
believed in it and you know it's also
there was a lot of luck involved if Joe
lumen was my college roommate and if I
didn't stumble the noodles office and in
Bushwick when ether was trading in 96
cents I'd made a whole lot less money
yep absolutely you know I just would
have I get credit I think because I
bought a lot and I held it for a long
time and most people would have sold it
and we traded it well but it was a lot
easier when it the money didn't matter
as much so I had other both intellectual
pursuits going on business pursuits
going on in financial pursuits it's
almost a sense of one of the things that
holds a lot of people back is fear right
and when you don't have a lot you
actually make decisions that if you have
less fear or you have more freedom
you're in power to make those decisions
and that's actually where the risk
reward is kind of plays in your favor
yeah fear is really interesting because
it's necessary right if I mean you're
walking across a balance beam between
these two buildings 46 floors up we
should be scared because you fall you
die yep and so fear is a helpful thing
at times where it's unhelpful as when
it's an imagined imaginary dragon mm-hmm
and your body locks into and often it's
your ego right it's oh god oh people
whatever people think about me five
and that that's completely unhealthy
fear and so he once had a shrink who was
yelling at me because he was like dude
you're not scared of all the things you
should be scared exactly you shouldn't
ride a motorcycle 125 miles an hour when
you not a really great motorcycle rider
like that's just stupid yep should be
scared and you really shouldn't be
scared of taking risk in life and
failing yep and I was like okay back to
the book back to the drama here well
it's funny that you say this because I
saw you tweeted kind of the top five
Daredevils basically in Alex Hunnam the
guy who scaled the big rock and uh in
the documentary that I recently watched
he has no kind of initiation of that
thinks that mega Mikula or whatever he's
he he has a smaller amygdala than others
that apparently comes from practice Oh
interesting
maybe its genetic maybe it's from
practice and so he gets less scared yeah
it's I don't think that documentary I
met him and and was just in awe it's
crazy yeah like the part that actually I
didn't know him other stories he started
to climb was like no I'm not feeling it
today
get down and then just came back one day
and said everyone tomorrow
six months later yeah crazy talking to
I'm not a giant climber but I have a
place in Jackson Hole and a lot of the
great adventure people migrated to
Jackson it's an amazing mountain and
talking to other great climbers and
adventure people lots of the thing no
one will ever do that again like no one
yeah like that's a once-in-a you know
not generational it's like once in a
humanity thing he literally climb that
thing with no rope yeah it is it is
pretty crazy
alright let's uh let's get some into
some of the crypto stuff galaxy you guys
got a whole bunch of stuff going on
let's talk a little bit about the asset
management stuff is pretty
self-explanatory you guys manage money
you invest it you guys got some balance
sheet stuff you're making so we have
four businesses if you want to think
about it and you know we set out to be a
credential Iser in the space I used to
talk about drexel burnham because I
think mill can really help credential
eyes you know high-yield and junk bonds
and they became a real part of
financial armory of for sure of all
companies and I think at one point
crypto will replace you know we're gonna
have a whole new world but it's gonna
supplement it's gonna be part of the
payment system in the world have
security token you're gonna crimp dough
and blockchain are gonna be integrated
into lots of both the consumer side of
our world and the financial side of our
world and we want to be part of that
process and so we have that's the core
you know reason to exist we have a
Direct Investing business you know we
invest off our balance sheet and on
behalf of one one other investor in the
venture space in credit in new
businesses in venture and gaming in you
know new protocols and in wallets and so
that's been the the most exciting space
and if you're sitting with people and
you've got like hey this is the new new
and what's coming down the pipes and
having never done that before into the
last few years is by far the most
enjoyable part of the business for me
and then quite frankly the hardest
because it's a learning curve trying to
understand what will work and what won't
work you almost feel like you're you're
getting told the secrets right that's
what I was finally these are the smart
people in the world and they're gonna
show up and they're gonna tell you
everything that they know and they're
gonna tell you everything that they
think is gonna happen and then you have
to decide whether you believe them and
they can do it yeah right like it's
incredible to have those people show up
to want to talk to you and tell you all
this stuff it's fun it's a whole lot of
fun and that's really the you know the
the juice of this revolution that's
going on there's a trading business that
were setting up and we're in the process
of you know getting good at the tokens
from Bitcoin and if their him to all the
tokens you know need to get bought and
sold and stored and and lent and I think
that part of the infrastructure is still
not as built out as it needs to be
across our space a lot of these
companies who are good at it slap their
technology together and it's complicated
stuff you can buy it off the shelf we've
tried many times
and so you know there's a race going on
there to provide liquidity and lending
services and in custody I think that's
gonna be a continuing growing part of
the business because I see
forget the coins we already have there
new ones coming we know telegrams got a
coin coming JP Morgan's got a coin
coming Facebook has talked about a coin
coming these coins are need to get we
trade it and store it and so there's a
big opportunity I think to continue to
invest in infrastructure so how do you
see the The Wall Street banks so I quit
so the funniest word to me in this
entire space is institutions right
because I think people who come from
more of a Wall Street background when
they think of institutions they think of
the JP Morgan's the banks the financial
institutions and then people who come
from a less Wall Street but still asset
management they're thinking of
endowments pension sovereign wealth etc
the Wall Street institutions what's the
general sentiment there right we saw
city go to build a coin they've backed
away JP Morgan is not gonna build one
like how do they all look at this so
they have a monster business and why
take risk on something that's really
small until they're convinced it's gonna
be real and so they're getting closer I
know Goldman for instance is gearing up
around securities tokens they're not do
anything yet but they are getting really
ready for the and looking at all the
questions on where would you store them
is you'd have to build your own custody
case someone else discussed see how
they're gonna work this is the
regulatory framework isn't there yet and
security circles where we were working
really hard on that on our security
token business and we've got I think
some cool things in the hopper do you
think that that's something that you're
not only excited about but will be just
as big as kind of the the tokens I see
owes all of that or it's gonna be a lot
it's gonna be a lot bigger and a lot
less sexy yep so think about something
we're one of the projects we've been
looking at is tokenizing a triple net
lease portfolio which is a bunch of
leases from a Midwest real estate
company maybe yield seven seven a half
percent mm-hmm like what crypto
investors you know wants to buy a seven
and a half percent you know none the
only seven to looking for the 7x
but there plenty of investors in the
world that would be thrilled with a
stable 7% and they're buying them now
mm-hmm and so all in some ways the
tokenization of that asset is going to
do is it's going to be at least in the
short on a call on liquidity and then
maybe in the long run some liquidity in
the short run you're going to distribute
it to probably the same exact people
that would have bought it anyway but in
the long run maybe we'll get to the
point where you get crowds crowds crowd
sale distribute and transferability will
be easier because you'll have that built
into the token and so it's a marginal
increase in the product there's a two
and a half trillion to three trillion
dollar year a private placement market
so each year basically there's two
trillion dollars of new public equity
and two and a half to three trillion of
private mm-hmm some portion of that
private is gonna get tokenized and so if
you're any one of the major banks and
you're like hold on I was part of that
and now if I don't get into the token
business I'm not gonna be they're all
gonna be part of the security token
world yeah again it's not as radical in
lots of ways as you know will change you
the payments payment network or or you
know creating peer-to-peer systems but
it's gonna happen and in part of it too
just feels like all they're gonna do is
they're really just switching up the
underlying technology it'll make some
efficiency gains a new wrapper yeah yeah
but it's gonna be a big big business mm
well and I think a lot of people in
crypto forget how large you know real
estate is or the credit business in in
trishal markets right I mean these
things but I said some of the other day
so look money is like what 85 trillion
or so give it you know globally real
states like 215 trillion so literally
real estate as a market cap or
addressable market it's just at least
two times bigger and so this stuff is
going to happen at some point I think
the big question right and I think your
articulation of like six months to six
years it is you know it's really hard to
tell on the timing of this stuff there's
there are there's architecture that you
were an investor in templum right
they've done a great job of trying to
get all the the regulatory framework so
you can actually you know buy a security
token listed there
but even how that world plays out where
where these things going to get traded
that questions still open right because
none of them are being traded are very
few for sure and so I also worry like if
if I'm in that trying to create the
exchange there's just no way that the
Nasdaq and the New York Stock Exchange
and all the big play
you know vested interests are gonna if
we really do have a big surge in
security tokens are gonna say well let
those new guys take all the business of
course right so the legacy players are
doing their homework and they're coming
in and I think one of the biggest things
I've noticed in the last year is you
know their capital to the space has
slowed down some but the venture
business there's still plenty of capital
coming in if you actually added the
capital being spent by legacy that's why
more people are getting hired in crypto
than you then used to be yep because
each of these places is working on their
their piece of it well it's more natural
right I think of a large Wall Street
institution it's much better set up to
go into security tokens then hey there's
this new thing that may replace the US
dollar right that the radical aspects of
this are just on the fringe and there's
everything from the regulatory
standpoint to just they don't have that
type of talent today right we think when
I think of galaxies out there like kind
of three buckets one is I'll put the
Bitcoin bucket but really is are we
going to have and I think we will a
market for what money is you know
Bitcoin versus the dollar versus some
algorithmic coin versus you know money
is really a social contract right
Bitcoin is worth something because we
say it's worth something if me and you
took the exact same technology and put
it out there and said hey it's nuovo
coin and nobody cared about it zero
absolutely bitcoins worth whatever it's
worth today eighty billion dollars or
seventy billion dollars thank you
because the social contrast and enough
people have decided that they trust it
and that it's that's worth something and
so I think part of and maybe the coolest
aspect is we're going through this
experiment that we are going to have a
market for money
mm-hmm that's kind of one second bucket
is really this idea of a web 3.0 and the
third bucket is really this tokenization
digitalization of stuff yep and so
they're they're different stories are
connected but they're not the same
stories and so we kind of break up our
thinking at the business and attacking
each one of them well what is let's
switch gears a little bit and I know
that you've been talking a lot about
surveillance in China and so stuff
that's going on there what was your
thoughts I'm kind of just again
technology is permeating a society and
the questions around how it's being used
and by who what's your thoughts there so
privacy is a giant issue in the world I
had a conversation with Lloyd Blankfein
and about this and Lloyd's one of the
smartest guys I think I've ever met and
he's a lot of fun to have a conversation
with and he was like never got your
wrong we've already lost it it's just
gone and so deal with it and I thought I
was just too depressing I haven't yeah I
haven't agreed with that yet he said
just be clear he's saying that I've
already lost before to see privacy and
so like we're gonna the the the new
generations just to learn to live with a
non private world yeah it scares me you
know this social responsibility score
that China is you know there were 30
million people last year that we're not
allowed to travel in China let alone out
of China because their social
responsibilities or right that so it's
not like a theoretical thing it's
happening and when you look at the
growth of AI and how good AI is getting
at understanding people's behavior and
you have data all of their data
basically being shoved into you know
government-owned database the other all
their spending data it's a really scary
thought and as I looked at a company and
debating to invest in that takes a
picture of you and instantly shows me
all the pictures have matched your face
on the web and your name and so I never
can remember anybody's name like this
guy forgot his a name already I take the
picture and I get his name I get his bio
that's scary enough yep imagine in five
years when you've got a bot that can
embrace through every last database and
you can sneak your way into
and find every last picture of him and
next thing you know we find a picture of
him going into an illicit place or quite
fraud going on the street interviewing
with somebody else yep and so it's they
you know I believe we have a right to
privacy and I don't know how you stop it
I mean there's lots of ideas you know
with the blockchain being able to to
help what about Facebook and you know
they've run into a lot of these issues
and now they're starting to talk about
you know do they decentralize some of
the products do they maybe give you as
the user a little bit more control like
how do you think a company that again
verse number of the banks they've got a
huge business and it's what it's working
but there's a lot of concerns and you
know people say hey what's around the
corner I think it'll be one of the most
fascinating things to watch over the
next you know six months to again of the
few years on how legacy companies who
are under attack because of their
privacy respond bald ones will respond
boldly and then others won't and you
know I think that the bold response is
needed you know I think the bold
response would help yeah I think you
know there's gonna be this is gonna
attack two ways companies themselves are
gonna realize I'd better change
mm-hm or I'm gonna lose some consumers
but governments are going to you know
Europe is much tougher on privacy than
we are and you're gonna see government's
regulate these guys you can already hear
it there's just too many too many breaks
yeah is this this in one of the most
scary parts of the technology that all
our smart friends have created you think
about this New Zealand video that went
viral of some jackass coming in and
shooting up you know all these innocent
people and you know Facebook has all the
vested interest of the world not to take
it not to let it go go viral they worked
as well as they could and they got it
down as fast as they could but it's
still a zillion people saw it I think
the number they said was in the first 24
hours ticked down 1.5 million copies of
the video there you go crazy think of
that Anna peer-to-peer sensorless system
like that ain't good like you know so it
shouldn't meet he even beyond the
systems you know they're they're real
ethical questions to ask will in trade
you're talking about here is so all of a
sudden there's this video that gets
streamed live there's no centralized
party to take it down right now
the counter-argument is in China you
have people who want to get words out
and say put on the theorem blockchain
right yes but in bad same system 100%
and so it's really complicated and it's
really nuanced and it's gonna take a lot
of smart minds to try to figure out
right the pure libertarians are devil be
damned and if there are 45 million
images of kiddie porn out on the dark
web and then the web crazy so you know
what kiddie porn is when people say
kiddie porn no it's pre verbal that's
three year and under like I don't want
those images in any society being
available to anybody and so it's really
an interesting debate unaware privacy
and how you do it and so again I wish I
was smart enough to know the answer I'm
fascinated with the subject there are
some things that are simple I don't want
my DNA go into 23m even though I like
that stupid stick years ago I would
rather that be between them you know
encrypted into a into a kind of a
blockchain database and you know
companies being able to hey together to
use that data that seems like the the
simplest architecture and and I don't
think what people would disagree with
that yeah the porn world and I'm you
know you can have your own moral
decision you know 18 and over okay maybe
but but when you're talking three years
and under of people that have no know
age of the sea I don't think anybody in
the plane would say that's okay yeah
well in part of it too is there's you
have to layer on than the regulation
piece of this right in some countries
there's much lacks much more lacks rules
than not and I think a lot about when
you go onto the internet a lot of times
it acts as a single country right you
know the laws that apply in kind of the
physical world so they're hard right if
you're you know if you go and visit a
website if it's on a server in the US
versus Canada versus China
sometimes there's impact sometimes
there's not right and that really just
makes things more complex I want to talk
a little bit about kind of criminal
justice and
and I know that you were really
passionate about kind of this bail
reform and stuff so I don't think a lot
of people understand some of the
problems and maybe just articulate you
know the two or three things that you
kind of think are the most screwed up
and and then we can talk about why they
are the way they are and kind of some of
solutions share so one of the great
windfalls for me of having bought
aetherium cheap and when i sold a bunch
and wanted to buy some fun things for
myself i to make myself feel less guilty
decided to give an equal amount to
charity or to a non-profit and okay with
it you did 50/50 weight out of clothes I
you know generally yeah roughly and so I
got behind a group called the bail
project and so I heard the story once
and that's all you needed to hear so
here's the story tonight in America 450
to 500 thousand people will go to bed in
a jail cell
a dangerous stinky you know unpleasant
cell having been arrested but not
convicted of a crime solely because they
can't afford bail so they've been
they've been arrested they're putting a
jail cell they're told you can get out
so you have X dollars yes if you don't
have X dollars you have to state jamie
diamond diamond from a JPMorgan
yesterday was talking about the two
Americas he said said forty percent of
America can't afford $300 or $400 the 16
percent of America can are fifty percent
of America can't afford like a thousand
dollars you know bail gets set at $600
$800 not only most people can't afford
it they don't even have a friend they
can call them and bail bondsmen don't
work on those low-level bails and so
they stay in jail now if you're in jail
you're seven times more likely to plead
guilty because you wanna go home you're
gonna lose your job you don't get to see
your kids you're you know it's in a
dangerous environment
and so you plead guilty usually for time
served and now you've got a record and
it's really hard to get a job if we bail
you out fifty percent of the time the
DEA drops the charges ninety seven
percent of people that get arrested
never actually go to court
Wow all plead out and so it's this
completely screwed up system based on do
you have the money to pay bail and in
that project what they basically have I
think we're evolving bail funds so we
raised a whole bunch of money now and we
are setting up in 25 cities to literally
show up at jail and pay people's bail
it's a humanitarian really direct
service getting someone out of jail
helps 40% of all prison rape happens the
first five days you're in jail
40% of all prison death happens in the
first five days you're in jail right so
jail is one year and under and prison is
one year and over and so jails retainers
go out to Rikers it [ __ ] scares the
[ __ ] out of you
absolutely or go to the the ship up in
Brooklyn and so I plunged into that and
it was this unfairness thing that just
touched on something and since then you
know I spent a whole lot of time I've
got a team that has looked at the whole
arc of criminal justice from pretrial to
probation and parole I teamed up with
Meek Mill and jay-z which was kind of
cool on probation parole they're four
and a half million people stuck in this
idiotic system of probation and parole
where you might be there for 12 years 15
years meets still on probation he came
to play a concert in New York City last
week he's got to get permission from to
go for a crime that they already
realized he didn't even do yeah but he's
still stuck in the frickin system with
it this death I heard and I'm gonna
forget exactly what it was but there's
some high percentage of probability that
if you go for your parole hearing so
you're in jail you're possibly allowed
to leave and judge is gonna make a
decision and the people who go within
like the hour and a half before lunch
get denied parole at a much higher rate
than people early in the morning I read
that once and so you know guess that
this is their life right yeah well in
the I've always just you'd wrap your
head around so if I'm a judge I'm
sitting there and somebody comes in we
convict them of whether it's drugs crime
you know whatever it is and we and then
they say we get to sentence them I can
say six years or seven years definitely
something like that big of a difference
that's 12 months somebody's life they're
gonna go sit in jail right and so
there's a huge there was there was a big
out roar when when
help me an important metaphor you got
four years only only and I was like you
know what four years a long freakin time
plus they're taking 28 million dollars
he's got to pay back plus he won't be
able to work and he's humiliated that's
probably a fair sentence what's unfair
at these crazy long sentences we get
people for a little crap and so we're
thinking about it all wrong we need to
change one of the things we did this
year we took 38 people to Germany
we took the prison heads of the beers of
prison from Louisiana South Carolina and
North Carolina Michigan Connecticut we
teamed up with Veera justice who have
been doing this work for 75 years and
toward the German in a Norwegian prison
system and start with same crime
one-third the sentence so our sentences
are three times longer okay but the big
difference is they look at the entire
system from it from a completely
different lens so the moment you get
sentenced the host that you lose some
Liberty mm-hmm everything else is about
your rehabilitation how can I make you
productive member of society again and
so you're treated like a human and our
system is about degradation debasement
the moment you get arrested you're
treated like an animal I mean you walk
I've been to seven jails now in the last
year and a half you walk through jails
like you you're [ __ ] right in public
you know guys are master I mean it's
it's you know you you start treating
people like animals they act like
animals and there's nothing about
rehabilitation in moving forward there's
a mean-spiritedness there's a punishment
side that like the letters call system
seizes on when I walked through the
German jails the US jails in the
Norwegian and I was just gonna give them
a grade Germany would be a 90 out of a
hundred in Norway to be a ninety nine
out of a hundred
the US has like a 12 really I mean where
we are it's barbaric up until February
of this year if you were a woman giving
birth in a federal prison you were
shackled hands and feet to the to the
gurney shackled in 13 states today
you're still shackled as a woman giving
birth in prison
he's freaking barbaric and it just it
serves no purpose I think we should do
away with the death penalty for a lot of
reasons one is that there are so many
people that you know unfortunately they
make a mistake that are indigent people
especially in the south that haven't
been provided the good defense there's
emotions around crimes that that show up
where DA's and jurors could be like a
mob mentality and it cost us a whole lot
of money
I even think these crazy you know triple
life sentences we have 10,000 people in
New York right state prisons right now
that are over 55 that have already
served 15 15 years the chance of them
committing another crime if you all let
them out is about zero that's just
statistics so we're paying all this
money to keep them in because you know
they killed something something whenever
like 25 what what I've learned in this
18 months i Doan is usually between 15
and 20 years in jail something changes
in somebody they take complete ownership
of what they done and they changed and
in fact I had to you know two guys who
had committed murder in my house last
week and I left him with my kids was
zero worries unbelievable decent decent
humans and so you have to ask yourself
in our health system do you believe
people can change if you don't you got a
different you had a different criminal
justice system I fundamentally believe
you're not your worst moment in life
partly because I've had a lot of shitty
moments myself and I refuse to believe
that's that's the that's the but that's
who I am yeah
you've got a you got a number of kids
what was their take on crypto or what
what do you don't know in terms of
Technology crypto you know my kids used
to get asked school all the time moans
once I started being public and they
were like yeah my dad's got enough for
all of us
[Laughter]
but they're like late teenager hobbies
no I've got a 24 year old who's you know
working in the movie business and a 23
year old who's teaching for Teach for
America in Chicago and I've got a 21
year old is still at school an English
major and I got a 16 year old who's a
sweet kid here in the city what one
gives you the hardest time yeah my 21
year old I was a good life what um what
you've also said going back the Crypt of
stuff every fun should own some Bitcoin
right not just crypto funds in terms of
you know macro hedge funds etc explain a
little bit more I agree with you and we
talk a lot about it with institutions
but why the funds it kind of what's the
benefit there
Bitcoin is it kind of if you step back
and like how cool like ten and a half
years ago we have this experiment the
social experiment we've got a technology
that allows us to create this sovereign
money really we've never had sovereign
money outside of a sovereign and it's
worked 70 billion dollars market cap ten
years later is staggering and so like
someone should bow down and you know you
know rub rub rub Satoshi's toke toes and
thank him Bitcoin in my mind has taken
this place of hard bunny or you know
gold has been a hard money so I keep
thinking of it like gold a store a value
it's clear to me that there's there's
architecture being put in place to allow
easier and easier adoption and access of
it and so at its base just as a digital
store of value in a world where most
money gets inflated away at a pretty
high rate you know the euros 20 years
old looks like there's arguments that it
could blow up a might not you know
there's a huge vested interest to hold
it together but man oh man half a Wall
Street thanks to euros toast average
currencies 27 years old and so you know
Bitcoin provides a really interesting
alternative to gold forget the other
stuff that might come out of it forget
level 2 solutions
payments and everything else just at its
core sovereignty should be expensive
people [ __ ] about big phones expensive
and I don't think it's that expensive I
actually you know wired you know from my
bread wallet $10,000 worth of Bitcoin to
someone we could go and it cost like 6
cents seems pretty damn cheap to me yeah
and so I think the the macro case for it
is pretty strong and so if you're gonna
put a couple percent of your portfolio
and there's a decent chance you know yet
catches wind we still you know fidelity
is just getting set up back continues to
get delayed a little bit but it's not
gonna get delayed forever they're gonna
be in the game and there's lots of other
players coming yeah it sounds like what
you're doing is you're making kind of a
qualitative look the the reasons why
this works check out right so that
they're legitimate reasons why people
want this asset and then also you're
making a non-correlated
asymmetric return you know supply demand
tight argument that just look if a man
increases the price is gonna go up gold
gotta eat freely another market cap or
seven and a half trillion dollar market
cap and so we're we're a hundred times
off on that and we're not gonna get
there in Bitcoin in the next year or two
but over a twenty year period could that
happen easily easily and that's giving
zero optionality to all the other stuff
of course and so I think it's seems like
a pretty smart portfolio bet you I wanna
make sure I get this right you sit on
the Advisory Committee of the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York or at some
point you did I did for three or four
years organizations like that think of
crypto blockchain like just knowing how
they think and and stuff like that so I
remember going to visit the Fed in 14
maybe with Dan Moorhead okay I took me
and and I because I I was on the
committee I called my so I want to talk
about Bitcoin and you know to be fair
they were really interested and they
were well versed even then and their
view was it'll never be a currency
because fixed supply currencies just
don't work they're too easily squeezed
manipulated and
but maybe as maybe as a payment system
and they love the black shading concept
and not baby says maybe as a a the
blockchain as a as a ledger they love
that that technology they they were
fascinated with and maybe as a store of
value
it's just isn't nearly big enough or to
reach their level of importance right we
have a twenty trillion dollar economy
and so I literally talked to one of the
Fed governors a week two weeks ago and
about stable points and he's like yeah
this you know no big deal yeah talk to
me they they probably should worry about
it more than they do but it's just not
on their radar yeah if he grows in size
they'll start paying attention but it's
just not there yet a problem is by the
time they start paying attention it'll
be too late for them to do much about it
yeah that makes sense
before you came I tweeted and asked what
questions people had and the the most
popular question my engagement was a for
you to tell a story of the most extreme
fun or savage thing that you've done in
your life I said I don't know how far
he'll go but uh but what story would you
tell it's kind of a this is Mike Novick
rot at his best when I I've told the
story about you know when I left goldman
sachs it wasn't a graceful exit and i
took a year to kind of sort my [ __ ] out
and you know you're depressed at that
point you're trying to get yourself
feeling better and me and two friends
went and we went to the sahara and we
did this race called the marathon of the
sands it's a marathon a day for six days
across the sahara and running running
and so you're running in a hundred and
thirty five hundred forty degree heat
and then it freezes at night you got to
carry your own food they give you six
liters of water a day and it was an
amazing life fulfilling you know he's
just you're like what I [ __ ] whining
about I'm in the middle of gorgeous
desert I'm running with six hundred cool
people from around the world my feet
hurt you just felt alive again yeah and
so when we finished it I had learned
skin on my feet like all the Europeans
they'd get a blister they'd quit the
race but whatever you quitting then if I
got a blister I gotta quit your goddamn
wimp
and so I literally finished with almost
no skin on my feet I came home in a
wheelchair but it just kind of
reaffirmed like toughness and life and
like stop whining yeah and I literally
soon after that like you know started
fortress or you know joint fortress and
you gone to the next chapter it is uh
events like that I think are very there
a reset button right means have you kind
of go through an event your life if you
just go I know people who've got
endurance races people have just you
know disappeared actually went to what
India for like a month right around the
Bitcoin etherium stuff I've did India
for many times for long periods to again
I have this thesis that we're all
screwed up like at our parents gross up
to my heart they try and so your your
number one mission in life is to sort
your [ __ ] out and there are lots of ways
to do it like I went to a one-week
healing center in Costa Rica two weeks
ago on an ayahuasca journey which that
might be the most radical thing I've
ever done in my life it explain a little
bit about what that is it's a
plant-based medicine that that purges
[ __ ] in your body that you don't need
and gives you a real therapeutic insight
to yourself you literally have a
conversation with yourself like you've
never had and you're like you think
you're talking to someone else you're
like let's just make and so it's therapy
without the therapist it's had you know
people there for all kinds of different
reasons you know for healing trauma for
healing pain or for just learning about
themselves it's not for the faint of
heart but I try to do one thing a year
where I learn about myself and so that
my second mission is then try to walk
each other home and to try to help out
your community however you however you
wanted to find that if it's charitable
if it's being nice to your cranky
brother if it's being a good employee
but like we all have capacity to help
each other out and so the more you sort
your [ __ ] out the easier it is to help
other people out yeah well one look one
of the things that you know before we
started recording we were talking about
is uh I look at all the drug statistics
and crime right so you know it's at 1.3
million Americans every year get
arrested for like simple possession of
we
right and 22 states have now
decriminalized this stuff and I think
from your standpoint it's okay look the
laws are screwed up and at this point
everyone knows we gotta fix this stuff
right but there's also an element of you
can use all sorts of different therapies
whether they're drug based or not to
help better understand yourself better
understand what you want to do in life
etc that to be fair I think a lot of
drugs are not good for you at all right
the world would be better off if there
was no cocaine it just wouldn't be
better off the world would be better off
if there was no heroin and so by no
means do I want to advocate for for
those use there are some drugs or plants
that really do have a purpose for sure
and from a criminal justice perspective
most of this should be in in health and
mental health and throwing people in
jail for being addicted to anything just
as a gets counterintuitive to them and
ever becoming a productive member of
society and so I think we should
decriminalize all drugs and it's a
radical statement because I just said
there are a lot of drugs that are really
bad like bath salts no real purpose in
this planet like you know if we'd be
better off without bath salts most you
know lots of drugs would you be better
off without and so you know it's a
complicated issue but like people
putting people in jail because they're a
heroin addict doesn't really help them
not become a heroin addict like helping
people deal with their trauma that led
them to become an addict that's what we
need to get society to look it goes back
to your whole point about the the
criminal reform system right the jails
and exception should be driven by
rehabilitation not by pure punishment
yes and the more that you can focus on
that the better the outcome is hundred
percent yeah I actually agree with that
a lot last thing for you CBOE recently
announced that the Bitcoin features
they're gonna they're gonna kind of
revisit etc I think a lot of people are
yelling and screaming on the internet
about this is really bad look you know
no one wants this stuff I take the view
that as probably the first product
institutions want to participate in but
where are you on this so how do you
think it affects the the industry listen
I think look
liquidity is always good for your space
I mean the reality is the CMA kicked
their butts and you know these guys have
limited resource of where they're gonna
spend their focus and they decided to
spend it elsewhere
finding leverage in Bitcoin is gonna get
easier as the the architecture of the
space gets better right you're already
seeing the the lending market around
Bitcoin went from 10% to like 3% so now
you can see once you can borrow you can
short and so now it's not so hard to
short Bitcoin it used to be almost
impossible to short Bitcoin absolutely
right in 2006 don't know how to do it
and so as the the lending markets of all
these coins get built up you can and
then all the sudden firms like us will
start giving people leverage once we've
done understand the customer well enough
and so it wasn't great but it's not it's
not critical again you look at Arthur's
business over and where everyone's great
where everything's based these days
gives you an unbelievable amounts of
leverage I don't love the way that as a
user I wouldn't be very careful he's
given what like 50 yet I think 50 times
leverage on a theory 100 on bitcoins
happen you know I listen listen I once
met him and I was we're gonna be mad at
the guy and by the end I was like can I
buy a piece of your business
I was like absolutely not how's it
please bless that he's built a great
business he's smart he's tight there are
businesses that are living outside of
what we would consider the regulatory
sandbox and you know it's another thing
that's gonna be interesting to watch
over the next few years like I can't
build a business like that beast in New
York I pay my tax I you know you can
they're there you know by Nance's living
outside of that regulatory sandbox good
max there's plenty of them and it's more
openly violating regulation and then
some are saying I'm just going to go to
the places where the it's the most lacks
hundred per site it was a very different
approach 100% and listen I think that's
all gonna play out the last thing I'd
say is I'm more confident today on the
space than I was six months ago
and anyone even a year ago because I
think you're gonna see in the next short
period of time a few announcements that
wake people up
and you're gonna look back and say wait
a minute this is no longer a fringe
thing like it might not be taking a huge
amount of of Commerce right now in the
consumer or the financial space but the
commitments that legacy players and
crypto players are gonna make in the
next six to twelve months the whole
world's gonna wake up and they're gonna
say oh this is real
I gotta get involved and so the decision
process around is this a real thing or
not just a technology work will it work
it's just do we even need crypto what's
the use case those questions are gonna
fall away much quicker than people think
I'll say you my god and so I don't know
when it's gonna happen I have a sense
there will be some big announcements
it's one of the cool things of being in
a in a seat that sees lots of product
projects and talks to lots of you know
both institutions and companies but I
think both on the consumer side and the
financial side you know the change is
coming again if I'm wrong I'm wrong by
some timing yeah I'm I'm more confident
that I'm not wrong that you're gonna see
this and there'll be a step function
when people like okay kripp does a real
thing because a lot of people still
don't believe crypto service I say one
of the things that from before I've
always appreciated about you and there's
you know a handful of other six seven
people who come from they're very
traditional financial backgrounds is it
always seems that you've had this belief
in the inevitability of the assets right
like of course this is gonna happen when
does it happen at what scale which asset
is the one that you know context lead
all of these different things are to be
determined but of course this is real of
course this is going to persist and of
course it's going to grow over time
right like to your point there's a lot
of people who don't believe that stuff
right like their stocks you're
questioning like he's crypto as an asset
class and as an industry going to go
away completely in the next five years
right like they believe that and I think
sometime in the next year a lot of those
skeptic
are gonna be like okay I give up and
they're gonna not do that just because
it's more the same old thing I think
you're gonna see some projects announced
that are of scale that get people
thinking and they'll sing you're like
wait a minute so JP Morgan the largest
second largest bank in the mirror is now
trying to get well no car they have a
centralized coin it's not not really the
same DNA of our spirit of the the spirit
of the community but but when you see
more distributed systems even if they're
not too central I mean decentralized
distributors it's a nuanced word I think
you're gonna see a kind of a mindset
shift okay I give the bankers a harder
time than anybody I'll start with the
whole long Bitcoin short the bankers etc
but if you take the JP Morgan coin for
example it's actually incredibly
intelligent its forward-thinking and if
you're in their seat that's probably the
best thing for them to do right is to go
and say look we're gonna use this
internally we're gonna kind of control
the risk we're it ease it for ourselves
and maybe a couple of clients and if it
works then we can branch out from there
but it makes sense for their business to
do that and one step cooler would have
been the 40 biggest banks having a right
instead of just JP Morgan running the
it's running the one node having a
distributed versus 40 big banks having a
coin and yeah wouldn't is good for JP
but it would have been then also you
would've like wait a minute
Baker coin banker coin all right before
we finish up I usually do rapid-fire
questions you don't answer a rapid-fire
though what's the most important company
in crypto other than galaxies well
that's a good question that's a good
question listen you know the I mean in a
lot of ways coin base is been the most
important us-based company in terms of
connecting to the the end user driving
adoption consensus has been a really
important company in terms of you know
creating this aetherium ecosystem they
were in our office last week they gave a
presentation it was a plus you know
block one is interesting that they
you know the EOS blockchain they kicked
out they have a huge war chest they've
heard a ton of smart people and they've
got a lot of cool things you know you
waited come June July you're gonna see
announcements that I think are gonna
gonna be exciting in that space and you
know we're still early enough in this
space you know there's a layer of
sovereignty I think a Bitcoin that is
slow and expensive that's gonna fit
value where where you would feel
comfortable transferring big value you
can take some time to transfer a big
value you know US has taken this
universe of very fast transaction speed
and so you hold more transactions less
value and so we're been investing lots
of gaming companies that are building on
top if it makes a whole lot of sense and
so how this whole web 3.0 plays out is
still really early you know we just had
cosmos come out and and so but I think
these companies that are investing lots
and the developers and the developing
communities are are the essential
companies in a lot of ways you know you
know for the space what's the one
regulation finance you know you got to
get by Nancy and he's dominating right
now and in recreating the energy of and
I don't know in the long run it's it's
it's it's fun and it's exciting I don't
know if in the long run you'll see all
these these new deals that are getting
done through his distribution product my
sense is they're gonna go up and they're
gonna go down and if that happens people
are gonna fade again like rerunning the
2016/17 playbook isn't smart for the
whole space it was a frenzy it was a
speculative bubble it was fun as you
ever seen anything like that before no I
have not I've been in bubbles before but
yeah I remember looking at the chart of
Bitcoin when it went from 12 to 20 and I
was like I've never seen a chart on a
log-log chart go parabolic and it did
and we kind of 2020 was gonna be the top
but at one point and it was just because
you could draw a line on a log chart
there's not a chart you can find
literally in his
three mm-hmm of any kind of large market
cap that goes parabolic on a long chart
yeah Hank's out the upper channel and so
that was a frenzy that you know it was
fun to participate in it necessarily
wasn't wasn't horrible for the space cuz
it dragged in energy and excitement it
wasn't great and I don't think we'd see
it again and so you'll see these little
mini versions of excitement that's not
really the next chapter of this the next
chapter is actually building a product
that works as getting you know
blockchains fast enough and DAPs on top
that our consumer you know interfacing
that are easy to use institutions buying
into those three buckets we talked about
you know the the the market for money
from big point of whatever stable coiner
ex-queen there is web 3.0 and then this
whole new world of digitalizing you know
old assets art you know non fungible
tokens of that so there are three
buckets i think it's all happening takes
longer than we all wanted to it's all
right it'll happen that's it what what
one regulation would you change your
improvement if you could I would wish so
we have an SEC who in their DNA under
the Trump administration says we don't
want to regulate a lot we already told
you the rules but I don't think that's
fair cuz we've also got FINRA that's not
approving lots of stuff and I wish they
would give a little more clarity so
really just get the clarity on a whole
bunch of stuff across crypto yeah
because what's slowing growth down right
the the security token world isn't clear
and so yeah you know what's slowing rows
down is that that level of clarity and
they're they're just still waiting yeah
I do think they'll make some progress
but that would be the fee if you could
knock the regulators and say hey could
you could you speed it up a little bit
wait a minute look I've always said that
you tell entrepreneurs what the rules
are right and give them confidence that
those rules aren't gonna get changed or
kind of pulled out from underneath them
and they'll figure how to build business
listen so the frenzy of the market
allowed people to you know go to this
idea of I mean part of the the the theme
of crypto was the democratization of
Finance
why should might never have to be able
to invest in a biotech firm or buy up by
an expensive piece of art but the man on
the street can't well okay let's
digitalize let's fractionalize it and
give him a chance well I don't think the
core regulators the Republican
administration in charge doesn't think
that would be a good idea their job
there was to protect the little guy and
the little guy got run over in that
process and there was fraud and there
was hype and even the whole ICO process
the way it worked I got in early and
then you'd get your buddies tokens and
you'd raise tokens and you'd hype it up
you had these up downs like that wasn't
good for anybody and so the regulator so
said no no no no the little guy can't
participate and I think for the next few
years the little guys not gonna be able
to participate in any of the security
coin offerings I don't think that's the
long term end I think once there is a
sobriety and and there are credential
eyes errs and there are there are
underwriters in the system we will see a
crowdsource distribution of assets that
retail never had it access to before I
do think that's the long-term end I
think we had a step back the regulars
like no no no no so it's it's it's one
step back for two steps forward
absolutely which it was controversial
thought and crypto what's the one thing
that you believe that you think most
other people disagree with I think we're
gonna well not should they disagree with
it I think in five years you're gonna
literally disrupt the entire advertising
business oh really
I explained that I you know when you you
look at the the the ability to take
there's a company of atomic Eric pull
airs company and you know he can create
that Jack a digital version of it or
Coca Cola's and imagine for flying your
airplane over New York City a real
airplane and dumping out virtual coax
and me and you with our phone just like
pokemons go or catching those cokes and
we can now bring them in and
convert them and maybe it's a new coke
and you've flavor every day and so we've
just done this product launch by dumping
a virtual good that's a unique object
that when I shift it from my phone or
from my blockchain to the to the to the
store it disappears from my phone or it
could be they did an experiment with
butterflies they have a bunch of
butterflies around if you caught one of
the butterflies you could get 50 dollars
to your charity or it could be a beer
that if I give that beer to five people
that actually fills up and actually turn
it in for real beer and so I think
you're gonna see gifting and advertising
transformed when we have this grid out
there where the the two-dimensional
world or the 3-dimensional world in the
virtual world kind of intersect yeah and
trying to seize it I mean look all over
Asia this stuff's happening right in red
envelope and WeChat and all this stuff
is happening and you know the technology
is there now there's a bunch of
companies working on it wax wax has a
new company they're gonna literally take
fancy tennis shoes and you can buy them
they're gonna put them in a warehouse
you know that people trade these tennis
shoes all the time it's a huge market of
trading on your fancy Nikes well right
now I got to sell them to you and you
got to sell them to them what if we put
the put them in a in a warehouse and now
we've got the digital form room and
we're just trading them around yep this
all shouldn't sit in a centralized
database yes they're building databases
to store tennis shoes yep and other
consumer goods and so I think you're
gonna see that part of the world shift
much faster than people think yeah
what's the most important book you've
ever read that's a good question in the
last few years it was sapiens sapiens I
think you know Hariri is brilliant this
idea that humans are storytellers and
that it's just a story is such a
powerful it's powerful on your
individual journey like everything you
think that's just a story I don't like I
don't like ants as a story you can
convince yourself to try any food if you
just unwind this story I was a picky
eater growing up now I will eat loser
eat anything my last thing was I don't
like going out like all sushi buddy now
I think Muniz literally the best thing
on the menu
it was a shift of mindset like we're and
so he he does that both on the
individual but he doesn't on the
societal basis yeah I thought that was
pretty cool
so before I finished up I always let you
ask me one question but we have to talk
about non crypto stuff which is uh
aliens do you think that they're real
you think aliens exist yeah go do
ayahuasca you'll certainly think so is
there other life force out there you
know there has to be a and I don't think
I've seen any other than in my mind but
just my my mathematical instincts tell
me yeah yeah we're not the only people
out there all right and so most people
think about space aliens all this stuff
as I've asked this question to everybody
it's got me to think more about the
depths of the ocean because we probably
actually know less about the ocean that
we do have space would you rather go to
the depths of the ocean or to space like
if you had to go to one which one are
you less afraid of going to you know it
all depends on it if we got the Star
Trek speed like I you know sitting in
and a space capsule going through black
for like 11 years to get somewhere is it
doesn't interest me but if I get that
fight if I go to the turbo or hyper
speed you show up hundred percent space
ok but I love the oceans as well I do
yeah I I just the bottom of the ocean
scares the hell out of me I think like
what's down there we don't know I just I
don't know all kinds of freaky things
yeah for sure
what uh what one question do you have
for me to to finish it up that's a good
question so hmm who's been your most
exciting guest you've had on this place
the most exciting or where you learn the
most that's really a question you're
gonna piss off the other ninety two or
three out there one to the highest
energy like most fun ones were Josh
Brown and reformed broker on Twitter and
Jim o Shaughnessy both on came in very
different you know kind of perspective
Jim literally came in and said I don't
know I don't know I don't know any more
crypto like five times and said okay
what do you wanna talk about
Josh just was being himself and when I
asked the alien question he out of
nowhere said it ghosts are more real
than aliens which you know that's a
strange answer to this day I give him a
hard time about but for those two guys
are the most fun I think the most
impressive person was cz and it was
really again just how he's built the
company scaled it so quickly you know so
many different countries and then my
favorite conversation was with the Peter
McCormick kudos though what Bitcoin did
what guests
he came on we didn't talk about crypto
at all and so I just gotta talk to him
about his life you know he's got some
kids and just kind of how he has built a
career lost a career rebuilt a career
now focuses full-time on this and it
reminds me a lot of like how your whole
gotta figure [ __ ] out you got a journey
in life and and kind of what that
journey looks like in the kind of
heroics involved that one was really a
really cool to to hear and then you also
said you did what six marathons in the
Sahara Desert and I'm sitting here
thinking about what crazy should I can
go do to beat that I got a list really
gonna enjoy this so I'll do it again
sometime awesome thank you another word
from our sponsors at total they're kind
of like kayak which helps you find the
best flights but total helps you find
liquidity by aggregating decentralized
exchanges and optimally routing trades
for execution remember that's total comm
/ pop t o TL e comm / pump go check it
out let me know what you think tweet at
me I'll drop you some fire emojis total
comm / pump one more word from our
sponsor block Phi their new interest
account allows you to securely deposit
your Bitcoin or Ethernet block Phi and
receive 6% annual interest paid monthly
and cryptocurrency this rate actually
compounds so you receive a 6.2 percent
bpy which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm / pump again block 5 comm / pump to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today
as we all know crypto makes tax season a
headache ain't nobody like dealing with
this stuff so let's then let her do it
for you if you go to Zen ledger io /
off-the-chain
you'll get 20% off your 2018 tax forms
these guys have a fast and simple tax
reporting tool that saves you time and
money that's right when you listen to
this podcast you get smarter and richer
one more time for the people in the back
that Zen ledger IO / off the chain go
check them out and let me know what you
think everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
a quick review goes a long way in
helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain